Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the 31st of October 1517, Halloween, the eve or vigil of the Feast of All Saints, a young German friar purposefully made his way to the castle church in the Saxon university town of Wittenberg and nailed to the door one of the most famous protests of all time, the 95 Theses. Within weeks, Martin Luther and his bold challenge to the authority of the Catholic Church were the talk of Germany, before long the talk of Europe. The 95 theses themselves, 95 pointed and often witty barbs,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1517年10月31日，万圣节前夜，即诸圣节的前夕，一位年轻的德国修士怀着明确的目的，前往萨克森大学城维滕贝格的城堡教堂，将历史上最著名的抗议书之一——《九十五条论纲》钉在了教堂大门上。几周之内，马丁·路德及其对天主教会权威的大胆挑战就成了德国乃至整个欧洲热议的话题。《九十五条论纲》本身，即95条尖锐且往往带有讽刺意味的抨击，
poked into the religious practice of the indulgence, were originally composed in Latin as the basis of a formal public disputation or debate at the university, but they were soon translated into German and put into print, the medium that enabled them to spread like wildfire. So that's the first paragraph of the book, The Making of Martin Luther by the great scholar Richard Rex. And that captures, doesn't it, Tom, some of the excitement, the incendiary nature, the danger, the extraordinary celebrity, all of these things that attend the story of Martin Luther, one of the individuals. Well, actually, I argued in an essay when I was 12, the individual who had shaped world history more than any other. And how do you feel about that proposition now?
针对的是赎罪券的宗教实践，最初是用拉丁文撰写的，作为大学正式公开辩论的基础，但很快就被翻译成德文并付印，这种媒介使它们像野火一样蔓延开来。这就是伟大历史学家理查德·雷克斯（Richard Rex）所著《马丁·路德的塑造》（The Making of Martin Luther）一书的第一段。汤姆，这段文字捕捉到了马丁·路德故事中那种令人兴奋、煽动性、危险以及非凡的名声，所有这些都围绕着他，他是一个……嗯，实际上，我在12岁时写的一篇文章中曾论证过，他是塑造世界历史最重要的人物。你现在对这个观点有什么看法？
He's top five, isn't he, Tom? Yeah. To me, he's bigger than Marx. Oh, for sure. Bigger than Darwin, maybe as big as Darwin. Yeah. Up there with the very greatest religious leaders who shape the way we think about the world. I mean, he is absolutely titanic, isn't he, Martin Luther? He is. And he stands at the head of this movement called the Reformation, which I think you could also argue is the most convulsive and transformative process in the past thousand years, with I think the exception of the Industrial Revolution. So it is an absolutely massive story. And Luther is a massive figure. And he has this quality of legend, because as we will find out, that
他是前五名，对吧，汤姆？是的。对我来说，他比马克思更重要。哦，当然。比达尔文更重要，也许和达尔文一样重要。是的。他与那些塑造了我们世界观的最伟大的宗教领袖并列。我的意思是，他绝对是泰坦级的人物，不是吗，马丁·路德？确实如此。他站在被称为“宗教改革”的运动的最前沿，我认为你也可以说这是过去一千年中最剧烈、最具变革性的进程，工业革命除外。所以这是一个极其宏大的故事。而路德是一个极其宏大的人物。他有一种传奇色彩，因为正如我们将要发现的那样，
account that Richard Rex gave us there, it's not entirely accurate and Richard Rex is making play with it. But it is this totemic scene, isn't it? Because Luther at this point is a monk, so he's very thin, bright, blazing eyes, a little bit mad, the mad monk, going and supposedly nailing up these theses. And this is the point that traditionally is seen as beginning the Reformation. So 31st of October, the date that this happens, it's been celebrated since the beginning of the 18th century as a Reformation day. And Luther himself as its founding father. And it kind of sums up everything that makes him the totemic figure that he is. He's challenging the authority of the Catholic Church.
理查德·雷克斯给我们的那个描述，并不完全准确，理查德·雷克斯是在利用它进行发挥。但这是一个图腾般的场景，不是吗？因为路德当时是一名修士，所以他非常瘦，眼睛明亮而炽热，有点疯狂，那个疯狂的修士，去钉上了这些论纲。这被传统上视为宗教改革的开端。所以10月31日，这一事件发生的日期，自18世纪初以来一直被庆祝为“宗教改革日”。而路德本人则是其开创者。这在某种程度上概括了他成为图腾人物的一切特质。他正在挑战天主教会的权威。
He's incredibly bold, amazing eye for PR. He's harnessing print, you know, the internet of the Middle Ages. So it's all kind of coming together and it's bundled in that single image, which I think is why, as we will find out, there's quite a lot of myth about it, but it's why it has that kind of mythic quality. And the other thing about that image is it captures, because it's so dramatic, it's very Hollywood, you know, the lone monk who faced with the great power of the Catholic church goes down and he nails his protest to the door. That's the stereotypical image.
他极其大胆，对公关有着惊人的敏锐度。他利用了印刷术，你知道，中世纪的互联网。所以这一切都汇聚在一起，并被包裹在那单一的形象中，我想这就是为什么，正如我们将要发现的那样，关于它有很多神话，但这也是它具有那种神话色彩的原因。关于那个形象的另一件事是，因为它太戏剧性了，非常像好莱坞，你知道，那个面对天主教会巨大权力的孤独修士，走过去把他的抗议钉在门上。这就是刻板印象。
And actually that captures something that is often missing, I think, from our sense of the Reformation. And it would be understandable that people would say the reformation gosh that sounds quite dry but the thing is it's actually not this is a story in which it's not just the effervescence of ideas it is the fact that individuals lives are at stake you know kingdoms empires are being torn apart by this it determines the political map of Europe for centuries. And actually, at stake for everyone involved in it, it's not just your life, are you going to end up literally on the stake or whatever, but are you going to burn in hell for millions upon millions of years? For eternity. Yeah.
实际上，这捕捉到了一些我认为在我们的宗教改革认知中经常缺失的东西。人们会说“宗教改革，天哪，听起来很枯燥”，这是可以理解的，但问题是，事实并非如此。这是一个不仅关乎思想的迸发，更关乎个人命运的故事，你知道，王国、帝国因此被撕裂，它决定了几个世纪以来欧洲的政治版图。实际上，对所有参与其中的人来说，赌注不仅是你的生命，你是否会真的被送上火刑柱或类似的东西，而是你是否会在地狱中燃烧数百万年？永恒地。是的。
So it's a very dangerous and exciting story, isn't it? So I asked Sadie, my wife, what did she think of when I said Luther? And she said, against corruption, but also just wanted to stop people having fun. There's an element of truth to the first of those propositions. The second one is more complicated. Yeah. Luther is quite good fun, isn't he? Well, the first half of his life, he doesn't have much fun, and the second half he does, for reasons that we'll come to. But yeah, I completely agree. So let I mean, let's just look at why the Reformation matters before we get into the life of Luther himself. So as you said, it's this convulsive moment in the history of what had
所以这是一个非常危险且令人兴奋的故事，不是吗？所以我问我的妻子萨迪，当我提到路德时她想到了什么？她说，反对腐败，但也只是想阻止人们享受乐趣。第一个命题有一部分是事实。第二个则更复杂。是的，路德其实挺有趣的，不是吗？嗯，他前半生没什么乐趣，后半生却有，原因我们稍后会讲到。但是的，我完全同意。那么，让我们在进入路德本人的生平之前，先看看为什么宗教改革很重要。正如你所说，这是历史上那个……
been Christendom, this kind of united union of all the Latin Christian states. And it sunders it completely so that people by the end of this process, are unable to talk about Christendom anymore. It's kind of so shattered. And you think about some of the episodes we've done where it's been fundamental to the story. So Lady Jane Grey, or the ones we've done on Cromwell and his time, or even the American War of Independence. But also just thinking about some of the ones that we've done recently that really don't seem to have Protestantism or the Reformation at its heart. The Nazis. So, the Lutheran character of Nazi support is quite important.
曾经的基督教世界，那种所有拉丁基督教国家联合起来的统一体，发生了剧烈的时刻。它彻底分裂了它，以至于在这个过程结束时，人们再也无法谈论“基督教世界”了。它被彻底粉碎了。想想我们做过的一些节目，其中它对故事至关重要。比如简·格雷夫人（Lady Jane Grey），或者我们关于克伦威尔及其时代的节目，甚至美国独立战争。但也想想我们最近做的一些节目，它们似乎并没有以新教或宗教改革为核心。纳粹。所以，纳粹支持者的路德宗特征相当重要。
1974, the sectarian divide in Northern Ireland, and even the Titanic, where it's Protestants who are building the Titanic. So, it is part of the absolute backdrop of certainly modern British and American history. So that's very important. But also, Tom, just to jump in, Luther matters massively in Germany, doesn't he? Hugely, yeah. So 2016, we went on holiday to Germany, and that was the year before it was going to be the 500th anniversary of the 95 Theses, which was 2017.
1974年，北爱尔兰的宗派分裂，甚至泰坦尼克号，建造泰坦尼克号的正是新教徒。所以，它绝对是现代英国和美国历史的背景。但这非常重要。但汤姆，插一句，路德在德国的影响力巨大，不是吗？非常大，是的。2016年，我们去德国度假，那是在《九十五条论纲》500周年纪念日（2017年）的前一年。
And they were already gearing up in Germany. And we were in Catholic Bavaria. But you could still buy, they were everywhere, Playmobil figures of Martin Luther. Yeah. Because the Martin Luther industry was absolutely firing on all cylinders, ready for this 500th anniversary. And the sense you had that, you know, he was a figure with the status in Germany that Shakespeare has, more divisive, of course, but with that sort of colossal transcendent reputation. Yeah, no, absolutely.
他们已经在德国做准备了。我们当时在天主教的巴伐利亚。但你仍然可以买到，到处都是马丁·路德的摩比世界（Playmobil）玩偶。是的。因为马丁·路德产业正在全力运转，为这个500周年纪念做准备。你感觉到，你知道，他在德国的地位就像莎士比亚一样，当然更具争议性，但拥有那种巨大的、超越性的声誉。是的，绝对是。
So that Quinceantinary, so Rex's book came out, loads of other books came out. It's been an absolute kind of spike in the study of Luther, which, you know, absolutely drawing on for this episode, a lot of what came out then. But just to emphasize how significant the Reformation is, it's not like it is history, just history. I mean, it is still blazing away. Something between an eighth and a tenth of the population of the world would count themselves as Protestant.
所以那个500周年纪念，雷克斯的书出版了，还有很多其他的书。这绝对是路德研究的一个高峰，你知道，我们这期节目绝对借鉴了当时出版的很多内容。但要强调宗教改革的重要性，它不仅仅是历史，仅仅是历史。我的意思是，它仍然在熊熊燃烧。世界上八分之一到十分之一的人口会认为自己是新教徒。
It's spreading like, well, like wildfire. The spirit, the flame, the Pentecostal flame through Catholic Brazil, through Africa, Korea, China. So it's still absolutely a vital phenomenon shaping life in the 21st century. But also it has an influence that is manifest, I think, way beyond institutional Christianity. The fact that, say, Britain has been Protestant for half a millennium, that America was founded as a Protestant country, the fact that English-speaking colonists in America went there as Protestants, this still has a kind of enduring influence, even if people in those countries are not
它正在像……嗯，像野火一样蔓延。那种精神，那种火焰，五旬节的火焰，穿过天主教的巴西，穿过非洲、韩国、中国。所以它仍然是一个绝对重要的现象，塑造着21世纪的生活。但它也有着超越制度化基督教的明显影响。事实上，比如英国已经信奉新教半个千年，美国是作为一个新教国家建立的，英语国家的殖民者作为新教徒来到美国，这仍然有一种持久的影响，即使那些国家的人们并不是……
professing Protestants. They are still, in their kind of cultural influence, even if people in those countries are not professing Protestants. They are still in their kind of cultural makeup, deeply Protestant. So Luther's rebellion against the authority of the medieval church, it kind of introduces into the bloodstream of Western culture some very potent and some very kind of paradoxical concepts. So Luther is about free inquiry, but there is also this kind of tendency towards moral absolutism. I guess that's what Sadie was thinking of when she thought of people in those kind of black hats. The idea of Puritanism. Yeah, telling people not to have fun. I think one of the legacies of Protestantism is individualism,
公开的新教徒。他们在文化影响上，即使那些国家的人们并不是公开的新教徒。他们在文化构成上仍然深受新教影响。所以路德对中世纪教会权威的反叛，将一些非常有力且有些矛盾的概念引入了西方文化的血液中。所以路德代表了自由探究，但同时也有一种道德绝对主义的倾向。我想这就是萨迪想到那些戴着黑帽子的人时所想到的。清教主义的概念。是的，告诉人们不要享受乐趣。我认为新教的遗产之一是个人主义，
but you also have this kind of consciousness of belonging to an elect. You are part of a community. Luther puts conscience at the heart of his understanding of what the good life should be. But there is also a deep Protestant impatience with those who spurn the light, who spurn the word. And of course, Luther is all about belief.
但你也有那种属于“选民”的意识。你是社区的一部分。路德将良知置于他对美好生活理解的核心。但新教对那些拒绝光明、拒绝圣言的人也有着深刻的不耐烦。当然，路德完全是关于信仰的。
So Alec Ryrie, author of a wonderful book called Protestants, says about Protestants that a love affair with God has been at the heart of their faith. But the other side of Protestantism is a kind of scorn for superstition, overthrowing of idols, all that kind of thing. So the indulgences that were mentioned right at the beginning will come to those pieces of paper that can get you out of purgatory. That kind of thing is what Lutherans set their heart against, isn't it? A lot of the trappings of religion, the physical trappings, they're very scornful of, aren't they? Well, there's lots of things that people prior to Luther had regarded as being
所以，精彩著作《新教徒》（Protestants）的作者亚历克·赖里（Alec Ryrie）说，对新教徒而言，与上帝的恋爱关系一直是他们信仰的核心。但新教的另一面是对迷信的蔑视，推翻偶像，诸如此类。所以开头提到的赎罪券，那些能让你脱离炼狱的纸片。路德反对的正是那种东西，不是吗？宗教的许多外在形式，物质上的外在形式，他们非常蔑视，不是吗？嗯，路德之前的人们认为非常神圣的许多东西，路德后来都谴责为纯粹的迷信。这不仅对新教徒，而且对更广阔的世界都有影响。所以，例如天主教徒，我们谈论天主教会是路德攻击的对象。但实际上，我认为我们所说的“天主教会”是宗教改革的产物。因为在此之前，它只是“教会”。是的，你不需要考虑它意味着什么。它通过必须在与新教的对抗中定义自己，才被定义为“天主教会”。
profoundly holy that Luther comes to condemn as mere superstition. And this has a kind of impact, I think, not just on Protestants, but on the much broader world. So Catholics, for instance, we talk about the Catholic church as something that Luther is attacking. But really, I think what we mean by the Catholic church is a product of the Reformation. So before that, it's just the church. Yeah, you don't have to think about what it means. It becomes defined as the Catholic church by the process of having to define itself against Protestantism.
（注：此段落原文重复，已合并处理）
Just all those things that you listed, the free inquiry versus moral absolutism, the individualism, their sense of being an elect, impatience with people who spurn the light. I mean, I think it will have already have occurred to many of our listeners that those are things that are very, very palpable in Anglo-American, English-speaking culture right now in the early 2020s, aren't they? It feels like a very Protestant moment. Yeah, I completely agree. One of the logical endpoints of Protestantism is a kind of atheism, because if you were
你列出的所有那些东西，自由探究与道德绝对主义的对立，个人主义，他们作为选民的感觉，对拒绝光明的人的不耐烦。我的意思是，我想很多听众已经意识到，这些东西在21世纪20年代初的英美英语文化中是非常、非常明显的，不是吗？这感觉像是一个非常“新教”的时刻。是的，我完全同意。新教的逻辑终点之一是一种无神论，因为如果你在……
overthrowing superstition, then you could end up banishing God. Yeah. Like a Church of England vicar, Tom. Well, as Luther does, he lays a massive emphasis. So he has this doctrine, sola scriptura, only scripture. This is the foundation of his teaching, that all the other stuff that the Catholic Church has been teaching, so indulgences will be part of it, we'll come to that, but all the other kind of panoply of doctrine, that this is irrelevant because it's not in the Bible. But you could end up following that logic through, get rid of the Bible itself, which I think is where we are. A kind of, say, progressive morality is a kind of post-believing Protestantism.
推翻迷信，那么你最终可能会驱逐上帝。是的。就像英国国教的牧师一样，汤姆。嗯，正如路德所做的那样，他强调了这一点。所以他有这个教义，sola scriptura，唯独圣经。这是他教义的基础，即天主教会一直在教导的所有其他东西，所以赎罪券将是其中的一部分，我们稍后会讲到，但所有其他种类的教义全集，这都是无关紧要的，因为圣经里没有。但你最终可能会遵循那个逻辑，摆脱圣经本身，我认为这就是我们现在的处境。一种，比如，进步道德是一种后信仰时代的新教。
So secularists and humanists or whatever, I and humanists have a very, very evangelical tone. Yeah, of course. They're very into overthrowing idols and stuff. I would say that that evangelical quality of Protestantism does remain absolutely vivid in the 21st century because America, which is the most, certainly on the Anglophone world and even beyond the Anglophone world, such a profound moral influence. That moral progressivism, which is basically a kind of godless Protestantism, you can see it converting countries that previously were kind of defined by the Catholicism. So I'm thinking about Ireland. I mean, Ireland in my lifetime has basically gone from being a Catholic country to being a country where the ruling
所以世俗主义者和人文主义者等等，我和人文主义者有一种非常、非常福音派的语调。是的，当然。他们非常热衷于推翻偶像之类的东西。我会说，新教的那种福音派特质在21世纪仍然绝对生动，因为美国，在英语世界，甚至在英语世界之外，有着如此深远的道德影响。那种道德进步主义，基本上是一种无神论的新教，你可以看到它正在改变那些以前被天主教定义的国家。所以我想到的是爱尔兰。我的意思是，爱尔兰在我有生之年基本上已经从一个天主教国家变成了一个统治……
ideology is a kind of godless Protestantism. The irony of that is obviously incredibly intense. So I really think that this is a massive theme and so much begins with Luther. It really is about Luther initially. So Richard Rex in his book, No Luther, No Reformation. Great key. Not all scholars would agree with that though, would they, Tom? No, they wouldn't. But I think that there is absolutely a case to be made for that. And that's the case that I would want to make in these episodes that we're going to be doing.
意识形态是一种无神论新教的国家。这种讽刺显然极其强烈。所以我真的认为这是一个宏大的主题，很多事情都始于路德。最初确实是关于路德的。所以理查德·雷克斯在他的书中说，没有路德，就没有宗教改革。很棒的观点。但并非所有学者都同意这一点，对吧，汤姆？不，他们不会。但我认为绝对有理由这么说。这就是我想在我们即将制作的这些剧集中提出的观点。
Right. That he's a genuinely transformative individual. Yeah. I mean, all the ingredients are there, all the elements for rustling up the stew, but it's Luther who's the cook. Okay. We love a metaphor, don't we? So we've gone from the wildfires to now weling up the stew. But it's Luther who's the cook. We love a metaphor, don't we? So we've gone from the wildfires to now we're in the kitchen.
对。他是一个真正具有变革性的个人。是的。我的意思是，炖菜的所有配料都在那里，所有元素都在那里，但路德是厨师。好吧。我们喜欢隐喻，不是吗？所以我们从野火变成了炖菜。但路德是厨师。我们喜欢隐喻，不是吗？所以我们从野火变成了我们在厨房里。
Yes. It's Luther who enables the ship of the medieval church to hit the iceberg of the Reformation. Right. Very good. But also the other thing about Luther is that he's a most unexpected person to have launched a great religious convulsion. Okay. Because he, I mean, he's not from one of the great powerhouses of medieval thought. So the universities of Bologna or Paris or Oxford, these previously are where religious
是的。是路德让中世纪教会的船撞上了宗教改革的冰山。很好。但关于路德的另一件事是，他是一个最意想不到能发起一场伟大宗教动荡的人。好吧。因为他，我的意思是，他不是来自中世纪思想的伟大中心之一。所以博洛尼亚、巴黎或牛津的大学，这些以前是……
philosophers and thinkers and theologians who have had a measurable impact on the fabric of the medieval church have tended to come from. But he comes from one of Christendom's more marginal areas, which is Saxony, right on the eastern flank of not just Christendom, but of the Holy Roman Empire of the German nation, which is this kind of weird melange of princedoms, cities, all kinds of bits stitched together, ruled over by an emperor. And this emperor is elected, and the Prince of Saxony is one of the seven electors. So Saxony is marginal, but it is also important. Yeah. So we're in Saxony in Germany. So that's sort of, as you look at the map today, that's Southeastern Germany and Luther is born in November, 1483. So to put that into a wider context, Richard III has seized the throne of England and probably made away with the princess in their tower. The Battle of Bosworth is two years away. Catherine of Aragon is going to be born in two years. Hernán Cortés has been born in Spain. Columbus is going around trying to rustle up investors for his great enterprise. And actually, Luther is born. So the place where he's
宗教哲学家、思想家和神学家倾向于来自的地方，他们对中世纪教会的结构产生了可衡量的影响。但他来自基督教世界比较边缘的地区之一，即萨克森，就在基督教世界，甚至神圣罗马帝国德意志民族的东侧，这是一个由皇帝统治的、由公国、城市、各种碎片缝合在一起的奇怪混合体。而这位皇帝是选举产生的，萨克森公爵是七位选帝侯之一。所以萨克森是边缘的，但它也很重要。是的。所以我们在德国的萨克森。所以，当你今天看地图时，那是德国东南部，路德出生于1483年11月。为了将其置于更广阔的背景下，理查德三世已经夺取了英国王位，并可能在塔中除掉了王子。博斯沃思战役还有两年。阿拉贡的凯瑟琳将在两年后出生。埃尔南·科尔特斯在西班牙出生。哥伦布正在四处奔走，试图为他的伟大事业招募投资者。实际上，路德出生了。所以他出生的地方……
born is a fringe, isn't it? It's a fringe of Europe. It's kind of German, slightly Slavic. It's a backwater. Yeah. So the elector German, slightly Slavic. It's a backwater. Yeah. So the elector, when Luther was born, he's a guy called Ernst. And he rules a chunk of Saxony and he also rules a chunk of Thuringia, which is the kind of the region next to it. And his capital is a place called Wittenberg, which originally had been founded as a kind of colonial settlement by German Christians planting it amid the pagan Slavs, people called the Wens, who were in the habit of talking to horses. They had a talking horse that would kind of reveal the future to them, supposedly.
是一个边缘地带，不是吗？它是欧洲的边缘。它是德国的，稍微有点斯拉夫色彩。这是一个死水。是的。所以选帝侯，当路德出生时，是一个叫恩斯特的人。他统治着萨克森的一部分，也统治着图林根的一部分，也就是它旁边的地区。他的首都是一个叫维滕贝格的地方，它最初是作为一种殖民定居点建立的，由德国基督徒在异教徒斯拉夫人中间建立，这些人被称为温德人（Wens），他们有和马说话的习惯。他们有一匹会说话的马，据说会向他们揭示未来。
They got on well with Virginia Woolf. Yeah, very good. And even in Luther's time, it still has a slightly colonial quality. So Slavs, for instance, are not allowed to become citizens of Wittenberg. And Wittenberg itself, it means the White Mountain, but basically there are no hills at all. It's all very flat, very featureless. And Wittenberg is pretty small by the standards of places further west. So it's about two and a,500 inhabitants, about 400 houses. It's pretty much, from the
他们和弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫相处得很好。是的，很好。即使在路德时代，它仍然有一种轻微的殖民色彩。例如，斯拉夫人不允许成为维滕贝格的公民。而维滕贝格本身，意思是“白山”，但基本上根本没有山。它非常平坦，非常平庸。按照更西边地方的标准，维滕贝格相当小。所以大约有2500名居民，大约400所房子。从……
point of view of Latin Christendom, at the fringes of nowhere. But the thing is that Luther is even more provincial, because he's not even born in Wittenberg. He is born in a place called Eisleben, which is a mining town. I was kind of thinking when I was reading some of the biographies for this series, that actually he's quite like a figure from a 1950s or 1960s kitchen sink drama. So he's the son of a miner who gets a posh education and then the father and the son kind of have bust-ups. Lots of people think that's the key to Luther, don't they? That he's this sort of Dennis Potter, Alan Silito dynamic where he's rebelled against his father, he's gone off to become an educated man, and his relationship with his father ends up becoming his relationship with the church or with God or whatever.
拉丁基督教世界的角度来看，它处于荒凉的边缘。但问题是路德更偏远，因为他甚至不是出生在维滕贝格。他出生在一个叫艾斯莱本（Eisleben）的地方，那是一个矿业城镇。我在为这个系列阅读一些传记时，心想他其实很像20世纪50年代或60年代厨房水槽剧（kitchen sink drama）中的人物。所以他是矿工的儿子，接受了高级教育，然后父子之间发生了争吵。很多人认为这是理解路德的关键，不是吗？他那种丹尼斯·波特（Dennis Potter）、艾伦·西利托（Alan Sillitoe）式的动态，他反叛了父亲，去成为一个受过教育的人，他与父亲的关系最终变成了他与教会或上帝的关系，等等。
Well, John Osborne, the great playwright of the 50s and 60s, in 61, he writes a play about Luther, Albert Finney, as the young Luther. Albert Finney. So Luther is born into this kind of mining community and he's descended from peasants. And he says actually that his father's a peasant. I mean, I think that's not quite true. So his father is not Luther at this point. It's Luder, so Hans Luder. His family seems to have owned a copper smelting plant. So that makes him kind of certainly upper working class.
嗯，50年代和60年代的伟大剧作家约翰·奥斯本（John Osborne），在61年写了一部关于路德的戏，阿尔伯特·芬尼（Albert Finney）饰演年轻的路德。阿尔伯特·芬尼。所以路德出生在这种矿工社区，他是农民的后代。他说他父亲其实是个农民。我的意思是，我认为那不完全是真的。所以他的父亲此时还不是“路德”。是Luder，所以汉斯·路德（Hans Luder）。他的家族似乎拥有一家铜冶炼厂。所以这使他至少属于上层工人阶级。
Yeah. And definitely his mother, Marguerite, she's from a kind of trading background. So Hans Luder has done well to marry her. And Hans Luder was painted late in life. And Kenneth Clark, as in civilization. Yeah. He describes him as looking like an old troll king. But in fact, if you look at him, he looks like Barry Humphreys.
是的。而且他的母亲玛格丽特，她来自一个贸易背景。所以汉斯·路德娶她是高攀了。汉斯·路德晚年被画过像。肯尼斯·克拉克（Kenneth Clark），就像在《文明》（Civilization）中那样。是的，他形容他看起来像个老巨魔王。但事实上，如果你看他，他看起来像巴里·汉弗莱斯（Barry Humphreys）。
Isn't he the great goblin in The Hobbit? Yeah, it all kind of fits together. Wow. That's the person in all human culture you'd least want to be compared with, isn't it? He looks like Sir Les Patterson. Crikey, for Australian listeners. So haven't archaeologists dug up their house and found that actually they had loads of stuff and loads of toys and things that basically show that they were pretty well off? Is that right? Yes, because Hans is very successful. And having begun with not Luther grows up. And he's, I mean, he is a kind of, you know, Yorkshire capitalist. Right. Well, there's milk, there's brass.
他不是《霍比特人》里的那个大妖精吗？是的，这一切都吻合。哇。那是人类文化中你最不想被与之比较的人，不是吗？他看起来像莱斯·帕特森爵士（Sir Les Patterson）。天哪，对于澳大利亚听众来说。所以考古学家没有挖出他们的房子，发现他们其实有很多东西、很多玩具，基本上表明他们相当富裕吗？是这样吗？是的，因为汉斯非常成功。路德成长起来了。我的意思是，他是一个，你知道，约克郡的资本家。对，有牛奶，有铜（brass，约克郡俚语，指钱）。
Well, there's milk, there's brass, all that kind of stuff. And I think pretty pugilistic. So there's a story that a fight breaks out in the pub and he pours beer over the two people who are fighting and then he whacks them on the head with the beer jug. So this is the kind of man he is. And he's clearly physically very intimidating as a father. So Luther later in life records how Hans whipped him so severely that the young luther actually ran away and also his mother again luther remembers how he'd stolen a nut and she beats him until his his blood flows and away a nut that seems so harsh then you're not selling the looters to me tom i've written the words in my notes just listening to you neil warnock i don't know if that's about right yeah possibly yeah neil warnock of course
对，有牛奶，有铜，所有那些东西。而且我认为相当好斗。有一个故事说酒吧里打架了，他把啤酒倒在打架的两个人身上，然后用啤酒罐敲他们的头。所以他就是这样的人。而且他显然是一个非常有威慑力的父亲。所以路德晚年记录了汉斯是如何严厉地鞭打他，以至于年轻的路德真的跑掉了，还有他的母亲，路德再次回忆起他偷了一个坚果，她打他直到他流血，一个坚果，这听起来太严厉了，你没能说服我，汤姆，我已经在笔记里写下了，听你这么说，尼尔·沃诺克（Neil Warnock），我不知道这是否合适，是的，可能吧，是的，尼尔·沃诺克当然……
is a football manager rather than a smelter, but he could be a smelter. Anyway, sorry, continue. So they're clearly also very pious. So they named Martin after Saint Martin of Tor, because the day after he's born is the feast day of Saint Martin. So that's where his name comes from. And they are particularly devoted to the mother of the Virgin Mary, Saint Anne, who is enshrined as the patron saint of minors.
是一位足球教练，而不是冶炼工，但他可能是个冶炼工。总之，抱歉，继续。所以他们显然也非常虔诚。所以他们以圣马丁（Saint Martin of Tours）的名字命名马丁，因为他出生后的第二天是圣马丁节。所以他的名字就是这么来的。他们特别崇拜圣母玛利亚的母亲，圣安妮（Saint Anne），她是矿工的守护神。
And she will play an important role in Luther's life, as we will see later on. Is she not somebody who Protestants will go on to claim doesn't exist? We're not getting into all that. Okay. I'm just going to throw that out there. I think they'd accept that she exists, just that you can't necessarily pray to her. Okay. So Hans is very upwardly mobile mobile and Martin is his eldest surviving son. And so he decides that he's going to invest in his education, which again, we were saying, is very, very familiar to any drama involving upwardly mobile minors. And he wants to do this, I think, because he wants Martin to grow
她将在路德的生活中扮演重要角色，正如我们稍后将看到的。她不是新教徒后来声称不存在的人吗？我们不讨论那个。好吧。我只是提一下。我想他们会接受她存在，只是你未必能向她祈祷。好吧。所以汉斯非常积极向上，马丁是他长大的长子。所以他决定投资他的教育，这再次，我们刚才说的，对于任何涉及积极向上的矿工的戏剧来说都非常、非常熟悉。他想这样做，我想，是因为他想让马丁长大……
up and become a lawyer. And as a lawyer, he will then be able to help this, I think, because he wants Martin to grow up and become a lawyer. And as a lawyer, he will then be able to help Hans with his contracts, with his business, and so on. Yeah, makes total sense. So the young Luther is sent to a school in a place called Eisenach in Thuringia. And one of the reasons that he's sent there is that this is where his mother comes from. And Eisenach is a place that is dominated by a huge castle on a great precipice called the Wartburg. And again, this will feature strongly in Luther's story. And it is famous when Luther arrives there as the home of a Franciscan monk called Johann Hilton, who will die at the
成为一名律师。作为一名律师，他将能够帮助汉斯处理合同、业务等等。是的，完全说得通。所以年轻的路德被送到图林根州艾森纳赫（Eisenach）的一所学校。他被送到那里的原因之一是这是他母亲的家乡。艾森纳赫是一个被巨大的瓦尔特堡（Wartburg）城堡统治的地方，位于巨大的悬崖上。同样，这将在路德的故事中占据重要地位。当路德到达那里时，它以一位名叫约翰·希尔顿（Johann Hilton）的方济各会修士的家而闻名，他将在……
end of the century, save the kind of the turn from the 1400s to the 1500s, confined to a cell in the monastery and supposedly writing in his own blood before he dies. And the thing that's exciting about him is that he is an apocalyptic prophet. And he is foretelling the ruin of the papacy, Dominic. Yeah. And the ruin of monasticism and the coming of a great reformer. No way. Who will change the world in the year 1516. Oh, he's just a year out. Well, I mean, the coming in the year 1516.
世纪末，即1400年到1500年的转折点，被关在修道院的牢房里，据说在死前用自己的血写作。关于他令人兴奋的是，他是一位末日先知。他预言了教皇制度的毁灭，多米尼克。是的。以及修道院制度的毁灭，和一位伟大改革者的到来。不会吧。他将在1516年改变世界。哦，他只差一年。我的意思是，在1516年到来。
I mean, Luther must be gearing up to it in 1516. So just on the apocalyptic thing, I think that's really interesting that he's there and this guy is there because Luther must have known about him. He must have been a well-known figure in the town. Yes, I'm sure. I mean, if you're writing things in blood. Yes. So Luther is now, this is the late 1490s. So Luther is in his mid to late teens, very formative time. And actually, if we zoom out, as as it were pull the camera back you can see why apocalyptic prophets are very very much in vogue in the 1490s and so on aren't they because there's a sort of apocalyptic tone to european life more generally because you know we think the headlines are terrible now but they're pretty dreadful at the end of the 15th century so the huge thing that has happened is that the french have launched
我的意思是，路德一定在1516年为之做准备。关于末日的事情，我认为这真的很有趣，他在那里，而这个人也在那里，因为路德一定知道他。他一定是镇上一个很有名的人物。是的，我肯定。我的意思是，如果你用血写东西。是的。所以路德现在，这是1490年代末。所以路德处于十几岁到二十岁出头，非常关键的时期。实际上，如果我们拉远镜头，你可以看出为什么末日先知在1490年代非常流行，不是吗？因为欧洲生活有一种末日基调，因为你知道，我们认为现在的头条新闻很糟糕，但在15世纪末它们相当可怕。所以发生的大事是法国人发动了……
this massive invasion of italy in 1494 which ends up kicking off half a century of sort of chaos and carnage syphilis is spreading through the french troops first time it's been known in europe and this is all going to culminate in the sack of rome in 1527 which is this absolutely dreadful moment but even more than that the whole business with the ottomans is kicked off in their balkans so the ottomans have expanded under mehmet and selim and then of course solomon the magnificent and the most famous thing which would have happened you know it must be in luther's mind as it's in the mind of every single person in christendom, is that Constantinople had fallen in 1453. Well, and not just Constantinople, Dominic, because in 1480,
1494年对意大利的大规模入侵，最终引发了半个世纪的混乱和杀戮。梅毒在法国军队中蔓延，这是欧洲第一次知道它，这一切都将在1527年的罗马之劫中达到顶峰，这是一个绝对可怕的时刻。但更重要的是，整个奥斯曼帝国在巴尔干半岛的事情开始了。所以奥斯曼人在穆罕默德和塞利姆的领导下扩张，然后当然是苏莱曼大帝。最著名的事情，一定在路德的脑海中，就像在基督教世界每个人的脑海中一样，是君士坦丁堡在1453年陷落了。嗯，不仅是君士坦丁堡，多米尼克，因为在1480年，
actually an Italian city, Otranto, for a year has been seized and occupied by the Ottomans. And so I think it's not surprising that Hilton, in his prophecies, says that the Turks are going to end up conquering Germany and Italy. But people genuinely think that though, don't they? They do, yeah. For the first time in centuries, they genuinely think these are the end times. You know, Christendom is going to be rolled up. Yeah. Islam is coming.
实际上，一个意大利城市奥特朗托（Otranto），被奥斯曼人占领了一年。所以我认为希尔顿在他的预言中说土耳其人最终会征服德国和意大利并不奇怪。但人们真的那么想，不是吗？他们确实，是的。几个世纪以来第一次，他们真的认为这是末日。你知道，基督教世界要被卷走了。是的，伊斯兰教来了。
So in his book on the Reformation, Dierman McCulloch says, you cannot understand the Reformation at all. You cannot understand what's going on in Luther's mind or anybody's mind at the time without realizing that as they see it, they are living in the end of days for Christian civilization in the world. That sort of darkness is coming. It's personified by the Ottoman Empire. And that's why when you look across the scene in the end of the 15th century, there are apocalyptic prophecies.
所以在他的宗教改革著作中，迪尔曼·麦卡洛克（Diarmaid MacCulloch）说，你根本无法理解宗教改革。你无法理解当时路德或任何人的想法，如果不意识到在他们看来，他们正生活在基督教文明在世界上的末日。那种黑暗正在降临。它由奥斯曼帝国人格化。这就是为什么当你审视15世纪末的场景时，到处都是末日预言。
There's talk of kind of monstrous births. There's all that kind of stuff. And Luther must be absorbing that when he's in this town where this bloke is locked up. Of course. And saying that there's going to be this reformer who's going to emerge in 1516, that the papacy is going to be destroyed, that the Turks are going to conquer Germany, and that the world is going to end in the 1650s. 1650s.
有关于畸形儿出生的传言。有所有那种东西。路德一定是在他被关押的那个镇上吸收了这些。当然。并说将会有这位改革者在1516年出现，教皇制度将被摧毁，土耳其人将征服德国，世界将在1650年代结束。1650年代。
That's very precise. Very precise. So this is all to end in the 1650s. 1650s, that's very precise. Very precise. So this is all the kind of the background for Luther's childhood. But against that, there is also this sense that the future is bright, that the world is being reborn, if you want, that there is a renaissance. Because Luther will go on from Eisenach to go to university in Erfurt, which is the capital of Thuringia. It's the oldest university in Germany. And although he seems to be quite an average student if his marks are to be gauged, he only kind of finishes about halfway, but he will graduate in 150 he is a brilliant scholar of Latin and particularly Greek. So he will translate the Bible directly from Greek into German for the first time. And it is in that sense that Luther, as well as being a product of this kind of apocalyptic environment, is also a product of the kind of humanist renaissance, which is very much happening
那非常精确。非常精确。所以这一切都是路德童年的背景。但与之相对的是，也有这样一种感觉，未来是光明的，世界正在重生，如果你愿意的话，有一种文艺复兴。因为路德将从艾森纳赫去图林根首府埃尔福特（Erfurt）上大学。这是德国最古老的大学。虽然如果以成绩衡量，他似乎是一个相当普通的学生，他只排在中间，但他将在150年毕业，他是一位拉丁语和希腊语的杰出学者。所以他将第一次直接从希腊语翻译圣经到德语。正是从这个意义上说，路德不仅是这种末日环境的产物，也是人文主义文艺复兴的产物，这在……
at the same time. So this, for people who don't know, this is obviously not humanism in your kind of Protestantism without God sense of today, like having a humanist wedding ceremony. No. So humanism is about the classical heritage and it's about a fascination, I guess, with books and words and stuff like that, is it? Is that fair? Yeah. And looking at texts kind of very closely. Right. So for instance, throughout the Middle Ages, the translation of the Bible,
同一时间发生。所以，对于不知道的人来说，这显然不是今天那种没有上帝的新教意义上的人文主义，比如举行人文主义婚礼仪式。不。所以人文主义是关于古典遗产，是对书籍、文字之类的迷恋，是吗？这样说公平吗？是的。并且非常仔细地审视文本。对。例如，在整个中世纪，圣经的翻译，
the Vulgate, had been in Latin. But humanist scholars are going to the Greek and indeed the Hebrew for the Old Testament. They're looking at the original texts and sources. This is a project that Luther will definitely buy into. This also is an influence on him. But when he graduates in 1505, it would look as though this isn't his future. He's not going to be focusing, say, on biblical scholarship because he's going to become a lawyer. This is what it's all about. So at this point, when he graduates, there is nothing really about him to suggest the detonation that he's going to end up setting off. Yes. Tom, let's just take a break and we'll be back after the break for more Martin Luther. I'm Marina Hyde.
《武加大译本》（Vulgate），一直是拉丁文的。但人文主义学者正在转向希腊语，甚至旧约的希伯来语。他们正在查看原始文本和来源。这是一个路德肯定会买账的项目。这也是对他的影响。但当他在1505年毕业时，看起来这似乎不是他的未来。他不会专注于，比如，圣经学术，因为他要成为一名律师。这就是一切。所以此时，当他毕业时，他身上真的没有什么能暗示他最终将引发的爆炸。是的。汤姆，让我们休息一下，休息后回来继续讲马丁·路德。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom, Martin Luther.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。汤姆，马丁·路德。
Yeah. He's a bright kid, right? Because he wouldn't go to university if he wasn't. And he wouldn't be doing all this. He's a bright person. But do we know anything about his personality at this point? So is he... For people who think Luther is a bit dry, he's absolutely not. He's very disputatious, hot-tempered.
是的。他是个聪明的孩子，对吧？因为如果他不聪明，他就不会上大学。他也不会做所有这些事。他是一个聪明的人。但我们此时对他的人格了解多少？所以他是……对于那些认为路德有点枯燥的人来说，他绝对不是。他非常爱争辩，脾气暴躁。
He's obsessed with the body. Impulsive, yeah. He's obsessed with sexuality, all these kinds of things. Well, actually, you say he's obsessed with sexuality. I'm not sure he is obsessed with sexuality, actually. That's one of the things that doesn't obsess him. But he does have lots of other obsessions, you're right. Scatological obsessions, I guess. Certainly scatological obsessions. We'll come to them. No, I don't think there's anything
他痴迷于身体。冲动，是的。他痴迷于性，所有这些东西。嗯，实际上，你说他痴迷于性。我不确定他是否痴迷于性，实际上。那是他并不痴迷的事情之一。但他确实有很多其他的痴迷，你是对的。我想是排泄物方面的痴迷。当然是排泄物方面的痴迷。我们稍后会讲到。不，我不认为有任何……
particularly at this point that would mark him out as anything exceptional. And again, what makes it all the more improbable is that I think that there is a sense, particularly if you grow up, I think, in a kind of culturally Protestant country like Britain, you assume that it's just waiting for someone like Luther to come along and poke at the rotten oak of the medieval church and it will all just collapse. Fat monks, corruption, people having feasts while the peasants are starving, fake relics. Tom, I hate to tell you, but I think for about the first 30 years of my life, that's pretty much what I thought. I mean, I kind of still deep down think was the story with the Catholic church, but you are now going to tell me that's not right at all. Well, so I think that assumption is hardwired into the very phrase,
此时特别的东西能让他显得与众不同。同样，让这一切更不可思议的是，我认为有一种感觉，特别是如果你成长在像英国这样文化上属于新教的国家，你会认为它只是在等待像路德这样的人出现，去戳破中世纪教会那腐烂的橡木，它就会全部崩溃。肥胖的修士、腐败、人们在农民挨饿时举行宴会、伪造的圣物。汤姆，我不想告诉你，但我认为在我生命的前30年里，我基本上就是这么想的。我的意思是，我内心深处仍然认为这就是天主教会的故事，但你现在要告诉我那根本不对。嗯，所以我认为这种假设被硬编码进了“宗教改革”（Reformation）这个词本身，因为当然，那是一个非常、非常新教的视角。事实上，一直到19世纪末，只有新教徒才使用它。因为我认为天主教徒会指出，“Reformation”，来自拉丁语“reformatio”，即重塑，实际上并不专属于新教。它是整个教会历史上持续存在的东西。事实是，新教宗教改革所推翻的中世纪教会本身就是“reformatio”的产物，本身就是一种革命性的制度。因为第一次宗教改革，这是理解路德的重要背景，因为第一次宗教改革……
the Reformation with a capital R, because of course, that's a very, very Protestant perspective. And in fact, right the way up until the end of the 19th century, it's only Protestants who ever use it. Because I think Catholics would point out that Reformation, which comes from the Latin word reformatio, remaking, is actually not specific to Protestantism. It is something that has been continuous throughout the entire history of the church. And the truth is that the medieval church that the Protestant Reformation overthrows is itself the product of a reformatio, is itself a kind of revolutionary institution. Because the first reformation, and this is important background to understand what Luther is about because the first reformation
大写的“宗教改革”，因为这当然是一个非常、非常新教的视角。事实上，一直到19世纪末，只有新教徒才会使用这个词。因为我认为天主教徒会指出，“改革”（Reformation）一词源自拉丁语“reformatio”，意为“重塑”，实际上并不专属于新教。它是贯穿整个教会历史的持续过程。事实是，新教改革所推翻的中世纪教会本身就是“重塑”的产物，它本身就是一种革命性的机构。因为第一次改革——这是理解路德所作所为的重要背景——因为第一次改革
happens not in the 16th century, but in the 11th century. And it matters because the second reformation is, you know, it's a reaction to it, but it's also bread of it. So I think we should just give a portrait of this reformation because it is what Luther is going to be reacting against. So the key features of this revolutionary institution that is the medieval church, it divides the world into two in a way that had never happened before in any kind of culture in the world. You have a dimension of the cyclum, which is the earthly mortal dimension,
并非发生在16世纪，而是11世纪。这很重要，因为第二次宗教改革，你知道，它是对那段历史的一种反应，但它也孕育于其中。所以我认为我们应该先描绘一下这场宗教改革，因为这正是路德后来要反抗的对象。这个革命性机构——中世纪教会——的关键特征在于，它以一种世界历史上任何文化中从未有过的方式将世界一分为二。你拥有一个“世俗”（saeculum）的维度，即尘世的、必死的维度，
and will give us the word secular. And then you have the dimension of the church, which is radiant and pure and constitutes the link or the religio in Latin to heaven. So there you have what will become the key dividing line, which we still have to this day between the secular and the religious. And the clergy, who are called the religiosi, these are the people who guard the dimension of the religio, the bond joining humans to heaven. So these are, dare I say, professional Christians, which is quite unusual anywhere in the world to have a class who take up, in some places, 10% of the population. Their job is just to be Christians. Yes. And they are marked by chastity, which again is very distinctive and which really
这为我们提供了“世俗”（secular）这个词。然后你拥有教会的维度，它是光辉而纯洁的，构成了通往天堂的纽带，即拉丁语中的“宗教”（religio）。所以，这就是后来成为关键分界线的东西，我们至今仍保留着世俗与宗教之间的界限。而被称为“宗教人士”（religiosi）的神职人员，正是守护“宗教”这一维度的人，即连接人类与天堂的纽带。所以，我敢说，他们是职业基督徒，这在世界任何地方都是相当罕见的，竟然有一个阶层在某些地方占到了人口的10%。他们的工作就是做基督徒。是的。他们的标志是贞洁，这同样非常独特，而且确实
only is introduced in the 11th century. And by their use of Latin, which is again a kind of marker of the fact that they belong to a universal timeless church. They have a very complex hierarchy, obviously with the Pope at the head of it. And beneath him, there are all kinds of different clergy. So there are what are called secular clergy, clergy who are operating out in the dimension of the cyclum with the laity. These are your friars and whatnot. So these are the archbishops, the bishops, right the way down to the parish priests, the friars, the monks, the nuns, these are called regular clergy. So these are people who are taking the narrow path to heaven, but the surest path
直到11世纪才被引入。他们使用拉丁语，这又是他们属于一个普世的、永恒的教会的标志。他们有着非常复杂的等级制度，显然以教皇为首。在他之下，有各种各样的神职人员。有所谓的“世俗神职人员”，即在世俗维度中与平信徒一起工作的神职人员。这些就是你们的修士等等。而大主教、主教，一直到教区牧师、修士、修女，这些被称为“正规神职人员”。所以这些人走的是通往天堂的窄路，但却是最稳妥的路径
to heaven. And they, in a way, are storing up benefits for the vast mass of the Christian people. Because like all revolutionary institutions, the church gets its validity from offering people the promise of a better life. So you have justice on this world, in the mortal world, and this justice is provided for people as a result of a kind of entire framework of law that derives from the church fathers, from church councils, from decrees of the popes. And these are collectively known as canons. So the framework of church law is called the canon law. And this is seen as expressive of God's justice.
通往天堂的路径。在某种程度上，他们正在为广大基督徒积累功德。因为像所有革命性机构一样，教会的合法性来自于为人们提供更美好生活的承诺。所以你在尘世，在必死的世界里拥有正义，而这种正义是作为一种源自教会神父、教会会议和教皇法令的完整法律框架的结果提供给人们的。这些统称为“教规”。因此，教会法的框架被称为“教会法”。这被视为上帝正义的表达。
And there's always a tension isn't there between that, the canon law and the separate hierarchy that the church has and its own practices, its institutions and all that stuff. There's always a tension between that and the local king, Henry II, Henry VIII, whoever, who thinks they're kind of invading my privileges. That doesn't start with Henry VIII wanting a son. No, no, it doesn't. That's been there for centuries. Canon law begins to be constructed in the 12th century and by the 16th century,
在教会法、教会拥有的独立等级制度及其自身实践、机构等等之间，总是存在着张力，不是吗？这种张力总是存在于教会与当地国王（无论是亨利二世、亨利八世还是其他人）之间，因为国王认为他们侵犯了自己的特权。这并不是从亨利八世想要一个儿子开始的。不，不，不是的。这种情况已经存在几个世纪了。教会法在12世纪开始构建，到了16世纪，
by the time of Luther, it's this vast edifice, as also is the edifice of the spiritual economy that the church is presiding over. Because of course, what it ultimately is promising is the promise of heaven, of salvation. But what will prevent you from getting to heaven is sin. And sin, if you're not going to go to hell, you have to pay it down. You have to get rid of it. And this is where indulgences come in. So indulgences, they can wipe your sin completely clean. But Tom, you're not going to hell straight away, are you? Well, so effectively, if you were sinless in this life, which is almost impossible, so even saints, you might go straight to heaven. But the vast
到了路德的时代，它已经成为一座宏伟的建筑，教会所主导的精神经济大厦也是如此。因为当然，它最终承诺的是天堂，是救赎。但阻止你进入天堂的是罪。如果你不想下地狱，你就必须偿还罪孽。你必须摆脱它。这就是赎罪券的由来。所以赎罪券可以彻底洗净你的罪孽。但是汤姆，你不会直接下地狱，对吧？嗯，实际上，如果你在这一生中没有罪，这几乎是不可能的，所以即使是圣人，你也可能直接上天堂。但绝大多数
mass of people are going to have to work off their debt of sin in a place called purgatory. So that's like a waiting room, is that right? It's not hell. A waiting room with fire. So it's like a lesser hell? Yes. It's like hell with a time limit. So you've been a terrible man. You're Himmler. You're going to hell. You're just a commoner, garden offender like you and I. We're ordinary, sinful people.
普通人将不得不在一个叫炼狱的地方偿还他们的罪债。所以那就像一个候车室，对吗？那不是地狱。一个有火的候车室。所以它就像一个较轻的地狱？是的。它就像一个有时限的地狱。所以你是个可怕的人。你是希姆莱。你要下地狱。你只是一个像你我一样的普通罪人。我们是平凡的、有罪的人。
We might go to purgatory for a thousand years. Who knows? I think in your case, Dominic, slightly longer. Thanks. Compare me with Himmler. But you could work this down. So you could make prayers to the saints and the virgin who will intervene with god yeah or you could you know charitable donations good works you could go on a
我们可能会在炼狱里待上一千年。谁知道呢？我想在你这种情况下，多米尼克，时间会稍微长一点。谢谢。拿我和希姆莱比。但你可以通过祈祷来减少这些时间。你可以向圣徒和圣母祈祷，他们会为你向神求情，是的，或者你可以做慈善捐赠、行善事，你可以去
pilgrimage and above all there are there are masses and the mass it's the celebration of the sacrifice of christ on the cross and it's made vivid and real in the bread and wine christ is literally present there and this is a way for the christian people to kind of experience a sense of common identity and commune with the mystery of their faith so this is why churches are set aside as sacred places so you have images you have icons you have incense you have all the kind of stuff that I'm sure would rouse your Protestant suspicions. I actually like icon stuff. I love an icon. Good, good.
朝圣，最重要的是，还有弥撒。弥撒是对基督在十字架上牺牲的庆祝，它在饼和酒中变得生动而真实，基督确实存在于那里。这是基督徒体验共同身份感并与信仰奥秘交流的一种方式。这就是为什么教堂被划为神圣场所的原因。所以你有图像、有圣像、有香，有所有那些我敢肯定会引起你新教徒怀疑的东西。我其实喜欢圣像之类的东西。我喜欢圣像。很好，很好。
I love the kind of the Orthodox Church. Big fan of the Orthodox Church. But the role that masses play in the spiritual economy is that they are kind of believed to transcend place and time and to link all Christians to the sacrifice of Christ on the cross. And therefore, they have an incredible efficacy in burning away the sins of the dead in purgatory. And so by the 15th century, the idea of wealthy people paying monks or whoever to perform masses for the dead has become a crucial part of Christian piety. So Tom, two points about masses. So one is, in a weird way actually, I never thought I'd say this to you on this of all subjects. I think you're almost slightly underselling what a massive deal, literally a massive deal, the mass is.
我喜欢东正教那种风格。我是东正教的忠实粉丝。但弥撒在精神经济中所扮演的角色是，人们相信它超越了空间和时间，将所有基督徒与基督在十字架上的牺牲联系起来。因此，它们在消除炼狱中死者的罪孽方面具有不可思议的功效。所以到了15世纪，富人花钱请僧侣或其他人为死者举行弥撒的想法已经成为基督教虔诚的一个重要组成部分。所以汤姆，关于弥撒有两点。第一，奇怪的是，我从没想过会在这个话题上对你说这种话。我认为你几乎低估了弥撒的重要性，字面意义上的重要性。
Because most people would only go and take communion once a year, is that right? And they would get the bread, but not the wine. The wine is reserved for the priest. But this is a moment of extraordinary power in your life, right? Yeah, it's almost as though you were approaching the heart of a nuclear reactor or something. The mass is the reactor that is powering everything. And it's so potent that only priests can approach it. And even then, only with extreme care. And for the laity, it's too dangerous to approach. Right. It's the bit, the Raiders of the Lost Ark, when they take
因为大多数人一年只会去领一次圣餐，对吗？他们会得到饼，但没有酒。酒是留给神职人员的。但这确实是你生命中一个非凡力量的时刻，对吧？是的，就好像你正在接近一个核反应堆的核心一样。弥撒是驱动一切的反应堆。它太强大了，只有神职人员才能接近它。即便如此，也必须极其小心。对于平信徒来说，接近它太危险了。没错。就像《夺宝奇兵》里，当他们打开
the lid off the Ark of the Covenant and all the stuff is flying out. Yes. That's the moment in your life, isn't it? Where, I mean, God is literally there. Yeah. Literally there. Literally in the bread and wine. Yes. The bread and the wine are the body and blood. I mean, God is literally present. But also the other thing I was going to say, that thing about saying masses for the dead to get you out of purgatory. But am I not right in saying that that industry, because it is an industry, is more developed in Germany than in any other part of Christendom? So somebody like Luther growing up, it looms, again, massively large in a way that it wouldn't if he was in Italy or Spain or somewhere where the mass industry is not quite as developed. So that explains why he ends up kicking against it and why it becomes so incredibly controversial in Germany and Switzerland
约柜的盖子，所有东西都飞出来的时候。是的。那是你生命中的那个时刻，不是吗？我的意思是，上帝确实在那里。是的。确实在那里。确实在饼和酒里。是的。饼和酒就是身体和血。我的意思是，上帝确实存在。但我想说的另一件事是，关于为死者举行弥撒以让他们脱离炼狱的事情。我说的没错吧，那个行业，因为它确实是一个行业，在德国比在基督教世界的任何其他地方都更发达？所以像路德这样的人在成长过程中，它再次以一种在意大利或西班牙等弥撒行业不那么发达的地方所不会有的方式，占据了巨大的地位。所以这就解释了为什么他最终会反抗它，以及为什么它在德国和瑞士变得如此极具争议
and the kind of Baltic and Scandinavia and so on. But again, I mean, it takes some time to take the dramatic step of kicking against it. Because I think to begin with that, you know, he's a schoolboy or he's a student. He's not really thinking about it because for most people who are not kind of professional Christians in McCulloch's formulation, it's not something you necessarily believe in,
以及波罗的海和斯堪的纳维亚等地。但同样，我的意思是，采取反抗它的戏剧性步骤需要一些时间。因为我认为起初，你知道，他还是个学生。他并没有真正考虑这个问题，因为对于大多数不是麦卡洛克所说的“职业基督徒”的人来说，这并不是你必然相信的东西，
in the way that we believe or don't believe in things, because this is part of the course of modernity that Luther is going to set Europe on. So I think for most people, it's just kind of part of the air that they breathe in. And I think it's one of the aspects of the pre-Reformation culture that is hardest for us to get our heads around, because I think that the way that the Reformation changes our relationship to belief is one of the profoundest aspects of what makes it revolutionary. So for us, what do you believe in or what don't you believe in? It's a crucial marker of our identity, but it's really, I think, different, say, in 15th century Latin Christendom. So say when Christians call Jews or Muslims unbelievers, they're not really defining them in terms of the fact that what Jews or Muslims believe is wrong. It's just that they don't believe in the stuff that everyone in Latin Europe is taking for granted. So Tom, I loved this section in your notes because it really, I mean, sometimes I'm very hard on you and the rest is history, but I think here I just thought, wow, this is so interesting
就像我们相信或不相信事物的方式一样，因为这是路德将要引领欧洲走向的现代性进程的一部分。所以我认为对大多数人来说，这只是他们呼吸的空气的一部分。我认为这是前宗教改革文化中我们最难理解的方面之一，因为我认为宗教改革改变我们与信仰关系的方式，是它之所以具有革命性的最深刻方面之一。所以对我们来说，你相信什么或不相信什么？这是我们身份的一个关键标志，但我认为这在15世纪的拉丁基督教世界里确实不同。所以当基督徒称犹太人或穆斯林为异教徒时，他们并不是真的在定义他们，因为犹太人或穆斯林所相信的是错误的。只是他们不相信拉丁欧洲每个人都认为理所当然的事情。所以汤姆，我很喜欢你笔记里的这一部分，因为它真的，我的意思是，有时我对你很严厉，历史就是这样，但我在这里只是想，哇，这太有趣了
because like many people, you know, I'd often thought, did people really believe this? Did they really believe that the body and blood turned into all that stuff? Relics, indulgences, how could they believe it? But I think what you're I know, for example, that human beings need oxygen to survive or that the universe was born in the Big Bang. But we only know that because everyone we know thinks it. We've been told it and we take it on trust and we just take it completely for granted. And that's how they thought about the devil, indulgences, purgatory, all that stuff. They didn't sit up at late at night debating whether or not it was true. No. Because it obviously was true to them. Well, I think a really fascinating parallel would be with, say, people's attitudes to epidemiology during the COVID lockdowns.
因为像许多人一样，你知道，我经常想，人们真的相信这个吗？他们真的相信身体和血变成了所有那些东西吗？圣物、赎罪券，他们怎么能相信呢？但我认为我知道，例如，人类需要氧气才能生存，或者宇宙诞生于大爆炸。但我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们认识的每个人都这么认为。我们被告知了这一点，我们相信它，我们完全认为这是理所当然的。这就是他们看待魔鬼、赎罪券、炼狱等所有东西的方式。他们不会在深夜坐起来争论它是否真实。不。因为对他们来说，这显然是真的。嗯，我认为一个非常迷人的类比是，比如，人们在新冠封锁期间对流行病学的态度。
Most people accepted what they were told by the epidemiologists, because why wouldn't they? It's the epidemiologists who know. And so the theologians are the kind of the medieval equivalent of epidemiologists. And you may wonder, well, how do they know? How do they get their certainty? And they get it because they have revelation in the form of scripture, but also they have what is called by intellectuals in the universities, scientia, so science, but it's not science in our sense. It's the knowledge that can be deduced from revelation via kind of deduction, via rigorous study. And so this is how purgatory comes to be deduced. Purgatory is not mentioned in scripture, but you can deduce it from various
大多数人接受了流行病学家告诉他们的话，因为为什么不呢？是流行病学家知道。所以神学家就是中世纪版的流行病学家。你可能会问，好吧，他们怎么知道？他们如何获得确定性？他们获得确定性是因为他们有以经文形式呈现的启示，但他们也有大学知识分子所说的“科学”（scientia），即知识，但这并不是我们意义上的科学。它是可以通过演绎、通过严谨的研究从启示中推导出来的知识。所以这就是炼狱被推导出来的方式。炼狱在经文中没有提到，但你可以从各种
conclusions that can be drawn from scripture. The whole edifice of this framework of belief is like a kind of enormous cathedral. You don't have to go into the cathedral to be aware of it. It is looming up over you. You know, because they're the experts. Exactly. And only a madman, you know, in 2024, somebody who said, well, I don't believe the world is round, actually. You know, you would be like, it's just eccentric for the sake of it. What's the point in going against what everybody knows to be true? Well, let's pursue that COVID analogy. Of course, during COVID, there are sceptics. I mean, there are people who kick back against what the medical establishment are telling them. And so likewise in the Middle
可以从经文中得出的结论中推导出来。整个信仰框架的大厦就像一座巨大的大教堂。你不必走进大教堂就能意识到它的存在。它就在你上方隐约可见。你知道，因为他们是专家。正是如此。而且只有疯子，你知道，在2024年，有人说，嗯，其实我不相信地球是圆的。你知道，你会觉得，这只是为了标新立异。违背每个人都知道的事实有什么意义呢？好吧，让我们继续那个新冠的类比。当然，在新冠期间，有怀疑论者。我的意思是，有人反抗医疗机构告诉他们的话。所以同样在中世纪，
Ages, of course, you do have people who are kicking back against what the church authorities are telling them. And these are people who, of course, are called heretics. And if they're inveterate as heretics and they refuse to recant, then they're burned. And in the 1590s, the guy called Savonarola in Florence, who becomes the leader of the city. But the guy you're going to be talking about is the real precursor to Luther. That's Jan Hus, right? So Jan Hus, he is from Prague. He's a scholar there at the university, immensely charismatic, intellectually brilliant, huge personal integrity, very influenced by Wycliffe. And Wycliffe is questioning the authority of the papacy, questioning all kinds of
当然，确实有人反抗教会当局告诉他们的话。这些人当然被称为异端。如果他们是顽固的异端，拒绝悔改，那么他们就会被烧死。在1590年代，佛罗伦萨有个叫萨沃纳罗拉的人，他成为了城市的领导者。但你要谈论的那个人是路德真正的先驱。那是扬·胡斯，对吧？所以扬·胡斯，他来自布拉格。他是那里的大学学者，极具魅力，才华横溢，个人品格高尚，深受威克里夫的影响。而威克里夫正在质疑教皇的权威，质疑各种
aspects of church teaching. Huss is influenced by him. And so Huss, following Wycliffe's example, is teaching that the Bible is the ultimate source of authority and that the traditions of the church are kind of irrelevant compared to the sanctity of the Bible. That the clergy are so corrupt that maybe the entire fabric of the church is corrupt. And again, he is scorning the claim of the papacy to have a primacy that's been given by God. And aren't there two other things that are interesting about Huss? One of them is that he says, you are being denied the wine at mass. You should have both bread and wine. And basically the priests are hogging all the wine for themselves. That everyone should have it.
教会教义的各个方面。胡斯受他影响。因此，胡斯追随威克里夫的榜样，教导说圣经是权威的最终来源，而教会的传统与圣经的神圣性相比是无关紧要的。神职人员如此腐败，以至于也许整个教会的结构都是腐败的。同样，他蔑视教皇拥有上帝所赋予的至高无上地位的说法。关于胡斯，还有两件事很有趣，不是吗？其中之一是他说，你们在弥撒中被拒绝领酒。你们应该同时领饼和酒。基本上神职人员把所有的酒都据为己有。每个人都应该领酒。
Yeah. And because this is, you know, it's not just a little glass of wine. No. This is the blood of Christ sharing in the radiant power of God. Right. And the second thing is that there's a linguistic nationalism to Hearst, isn't there? So he wants lots of stuff to be in the Czech language, a bit like Wycliffe with the English language, and that that will play a part in the later Reformation.
是的。因为这，你知道，这不仅仅是一小杯酒。不。这是基督的血，分享着上帝光辉的力量。没错。第二件事是胡斯有一种语言民族主义，不是吗？所以他希望很多东西用捷克语，有点像威克里夫用英语，这将在后来的宗教改革中发挥作用。
Well, that's more complicated because actually, so Wycliffe translates the Bible into English, but it's condemned not because he's translated it into English, but because it's associated with him and his heretical followers. So it's over the course of the 15th century that an association on the part of the church authorities is starting to develop with heresy and with the Bible in vernacular languages, so not in Latin. But it's not been absolutely solidified at this point. But there's a hint of it, right? Yeah, there is a hint. It really only gets kind of bedded down in the 16th century as a reaction to the Reformation. But yeah, that is a part of it as well. So Hus is seen as a troublemaker. He gets invited to a church council in 1414 that is being held
嗯，这更复杂，因为实际上，威克里夫将圣经翻译成英语，但他被谴责并不是因为他把它翻译成英语，而是因为它与他和他的异端追随者联系在一起。所以是在15世纪的过程中，教会当局开始将异端与用白话文（即非拉丁语）书写的圣经联系起来。但在这一点上还没有完全固化。但有这种迹象，对吧？是的，确实有迹象。它直到16世纪作为对宗教改革的反应才真正定型。但是的，这也是其中的一部分。所以胡斯被视为麻烦制造者。他被邀请参加1414年举行的教会会议
in the Swiss city of Constance. He is given a safe conduct there by the imperial authorities, by the guy who will go on to become the emperor. And so he arrives there in November 1414. Three weeks later, he is arrested. He's put on trial. He's told to recant. He doesn't. He's burnt at the stake and his ashes are dumped in the Rhine. Oh, that's harsh and so that i mean that's a kind of a chilling example of what can happen if you you push the church too far right but i think it is important to emphasize that not everyone who says that the church is corrupt or that it needs reform or that improvements can be made is seen as a heretic.
在瑞士城市康斯坦茨。他得到了帝国当局，即后来成为皇帝的那个人提供的安全通行证。所以他在1414年11月到达那里。三周后，他被捕了。他被审判。他被告知要悔改。他没有。他在火刑柱上被烧死，骨灰被倒进了莱茵河。哦，那太残酷了，所以我的意思是，这是一个令人不寒而栗的例子，说明如果你把教会逼得太紧会发生什么，对吧？但我认为强调这一点很重要：并不是每个说教会腐败、需要改革或可以改进的人都被视为异端。
This is something that is part of the fabric of the traditions of the medieval church. So you can go too far and end up burnt, but equally you can make these arguments and absolutely stay within the fabric of the church. And doesn't that reflect the fact that the church is not static, that Christianity is not a fixed thing and that there are always arguments going on like should the pope have power or should it be councils of clergymen what is the exact relationship between church and state as it were so the pope's always falling out with secular rulers isn't he yeah this is constantly being negotiated so just to go back to the thing that we began this with, so indulgences. I mean, this is what Chaucer's pardoner is selling, the most loathsome figure
这是中世纪教会传统结构的一部分。所以你可以走得太远最终被烧死，但同样你也可以提出这些论点并完全留在教会的结构之内。这难道不反映了教会不是静态的，基督教不是固定的东西，而且总是有争论在进行吗？比如教皇应该有权力吗？还是应该由神职人员组成的会议来决定？教会与国家之间的确切关系是什么？所以教皇总是与世俗统治者发生冲突，不是吗？是的，这一直在协商中。所以回到我们开始的话题，赎罪券。我的意思是，这就是乔叟的“免罪符贩子”在卖的东西，那是
in the Canterbury Tales we talked about in our episode. I mean, he's terrible. But Chaucer is not condemned as a heretic. He ends up buried in Westminster Abbey. You can criticise aspects of this spiritual economy, if you want to call it that, and be a completely devout Catholic Christian. So I think it's in that sense that there is nothing inevitable about the Reformation. You can criticise the church, but you don't have to pull the whole fabric down. So again, the question is, why does it end up kicking off in 1517, this kind of indulgence, his bust up that we began this episode with? And equally, why does it end up kicking off with this guy who we left? He's just graduated from university. His father wants him to go and
我们在那一集中谈到的《坎特伯雷故事集》中最令人厌恶的人物。我的意思是，他太糟糕了。但乔叟并没有被谴责为异端。他最终被安葬在威斯敏斯特教堂。如果你愿意，你可以批评这种精神经济的各个方面，同时仍然是一个完全虔诚的天主教徒。所以我认为从这个意义上说，宗教改革并非不可避免。你可以批评教会，但你不必推翻整个结构。所以问题再次回到，为什么它最终在1517年爆发，就是我们这集开头提到的那种赎罪券的争吵？同样，为什么它最终会从我们刚才提到的那个人身上爆发？他刚从大学毕业。他父亲想让他去
be a lawyer. There's nothing about him that suggests he's going to precipitate this globally significant transformation in the way that Christians in Latin Europe think about themselves. What is it that happens? All right. Well, Tom, this was meant to be like the first 10 minutes or so of the episode, but it's become the whole episode, which is great because I find it such a rich and interesting subject. So for those of you who are members of our very own little sect, the Rest is History Club, you can, of course, hear the rest of the episodes right now.
做一名律师。他身上没有任何迹象表明他会引发这种全球性的、关于拉丁欧洲基督徒如何看待自己的重大转变。到底发生了什么？好吧，汤姆，这本来应该是这一集的前10分钟左右，但它变成了整集，这很好，因为我觉得这是一个非常丰富且有趣的主题。所以对于那些是我们自己的小教派——“历史就是这样”俱乐部成员的人，你们当然现在就可以听到剩下的部分了。
So you can find out what turned Luther against the church, all the crazy stuff that happened. There's lots of sort of blood and thunder to come. So you can dig into that right away. For those of you who are still loyal to the old ways of listening to an episode every, you know, when it comes out, that's great. You know, we like you too. We don't condemn you. Yeah.
所以你可以找出是什么让路德反抗教会，所有发生的疯狂事情。还有很多血腥和雷霆般的事件即将到来。所以你可以立即深入了解。对于那些仍然忠于每当一集发布时就听一集的旧方式的人来说，那也很好。你知道，我们也喜欢你们。我们不谴责你们。是的。
You'll have to wait until the official release. Either way, we'll be back with more Martin Luther excitement next time. Tom, thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull
你们将不得不等到正式发布。无论如何，下次我们会带着更多关于马丁·路德的精彩内容回来。汤姆，非常感谢，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《历史就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开
back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members members club if you want ad-free listening bonus There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐的帷幕，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听和额外内容。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。